my guest tonight is a comedian he claims
uh who was a cast member on saturday
night live
and starred in the tv shows man with a
plan and weeds
his virtual comedy show kevin nealon
behind
the mask streams live on saturday
please welcome my very good friend of
way too long kevin neal and kevin how
are you
i'm good conan how you doing buddy i'm
doing great you know i love that you're
standing this is very dynamic what
you're doing you're standing
you look like you're just really ready
to go i do everything standing up now
i have a stand-up desk i have a stand-up
car
i have a stand-up bed everything's
standing for me now a stand-up car in a
stand-up bed that just uh
sounds well it sounds idiotic i have to
be honest with you well it's not
let's not be name-calling so early right
you're right you're right let's let's do
this nicely
you and i have been friends uh for quite
a long time we hang out a lot
and i happen to know that you recently
went through
shoulder surgery i saw you just before
you were going to have the surgery
how did it go well yeah there's the
what's left of the shoulder
it went well they replaced my shoulder
and you were nice enough to send me this
gift basket
worth 167 because you left the receipt
in the bag and of course i looked at it
it's all bakery goods yeah i know i know
i just wanted you to know how much i
spent
it was 167 yeah of
of baked goods and that's a lot that's a
lot of money i spent on you
and but you know it was like six loaves
of bread
which i could never eat you know they
and it was good bread too it was from
the uh nice bakery
no preservatives so it got moldy after
an hour
no i know that was the idea and then the
croissants and the chocolate croissants
and all the pastries i mean
i had to give a lot of it away to the
gardener okay
well i think it's the thought that
counts and the fact
that it cost 167 dollars but it was
really nice i appreciate that i've been
telling everybody like you asked me to
i've been good
did you tell the trades variety
hollywood reporters told the trades i
told the
uh deadline good but i think solder
comes from
the stand-up desk because i i still sit
on my chair
so it's like i'm always like reaching up
on my shoulder right so you have a st
that's terrible a stand up
and you still sit in a regular chair
that's not right yeah yeah okay that's
not good
that's not good you should probably stop
doing that but you feel okay you can
move
you can move the old wing as we call it
no it's been a couple of weeks so i'm
not going crazy it's just been this
right side
yeah um but it feels actually pretty
good the hardest thing is sleeping at
night
yeah not because of the shoulders but
because of the stand-up bed
yeah and probably your conscience you've
done a lot of bad things in your life
that is true man but i have not been
canceled yet i have not been canceled
oh they'll get you they certainly will
hey how's your family how are they doing
uh family's doing well conan uh you know
we our kids used to go to the same
school
and now all the kids go to this my kid i
miss him he went off to a private school
45 000 a year from our kitchen online i
know
everyone's no matter so does that bother
you that you're paying that much
yeah fancy private school and he's in
the kitchen on zoom
yes it does i'm i'm trying to get my
money's worth i'm sitting
next to him and taking some classes but
i'm out of frame so the teacher doesn't
see me like i took some digital
photography yesterday
or uh yeah yesterday it was a good class
and then tuesday's algebra which i might
skip
but i'm looking forward to thursday is
the guidance counselor meeting i'm going
to go to
oh you're going to go to the guidance
counselor meeting yeah because it's a
lot cheaper than a uh a therapist you
know
[Laughter]
you're not supposed to talk to your
child's guidance counselor about your
personal problems
i guess not but here's what i'm thinking
conan tell me if you're on board with
this
wouldn't it be cheaper to
just keep your kid home forget the
online stuff and just have them listen
to ted talks and watch jeopardy
for like a year it would be cheaper for
sure
yeah and maybe just as good an education
problem you know probably not quite as
good but close
i think you've got a good idea there i
really do
i have a lot of good ideas well let's
not get crazy
you know i will say this i visited you
as i said
and i hate to repeat this but just
before your surgery i think i'm the only
real friend that came over to visit you
and i noticed that you and your wife
were very good about masks
social distancing you did it we ate
outside
um it was it was very nicely done uh and
i was proud of you
thank you well you know you have to be
responsible in these colgate times yeah
um the the difficulty with the mask is
um i don't get recognized as much
anymore
and i like i don't know about you conan
but i think you like attention you like
to get recognized
i think we all like like it when we walk
down the street and
you know attractive women just go crazy
for us
yeah so what i've done was i've created
a mask
that looks exactly like this part of me
and yet still not recognized really
still not getting recognized
but here's the great thing about the
mask you could
let your nose hairs just grow forever
you don't have to brush your teeth right
you don't need braces
yep you can actually use the nose hair
to tie the mask on to secure the mask
this is all good advice like you said i
have a lot of good advice and theories
you know i think between covid and your
your shoulder surgery you've had a lot
of time to think
um not about good or productive things
but you're you're generating a lot
that's what i'll say well it's not a lot
of time to think it's a lot of time to
take painkillers
so this is all coming from the
painkillers uh-huh uh-huh
well just save me a pill or two if you
know what i mean
what do you mean not only do i know what
you mean but i hear what you're saying
yeah and i said it very explicitly so i
don't know why i said if you know what i
mean
i basically just told you to save me two
pills but you are um you're not a pill
taker i know that
i'm not i'm not a pill taker you grew up
in a very strict catholic family
my father my father's a doctor there was
uh no
you know we didn't take medicines for
anything we didn't take aspirin
uh we never took any uh antibiotics
um most of my brothers and sisters
passed away in early childhood
uh i was one of the only survivors but i
still
accidentally passed away yeah yeah was
not intentional they just you know
we didn't have modern we didn't have
modern medicine you know my father
as a as a doctor didn't believe in
modern medicine
no what about western medicine uh no
he likes northern medicine northern
medicine is the most underrated medicine
in the world
it's fixing everything with ice like
yeah
look at that it's all ice yeah
there you go i've been living in an ice
block conan for like the last
five years my body has never been
without an ice pack on something
it's an attractive look for you to have
those ice packs on
you hey let's talk about something we
can both relate to because we don't live
too far from each other
a lot of wildfires right now in our part
of uh california are you worried do you
worry about the fires are you prepared
well of course i worry about the fires
why wouldn't i worry about the fires
well it's a question i was told to ask
you i thought you had a comedy bit
ready to go so um that's why i asked
well even if you didn't ask i would tell
you that i'm worried about the fires
uh-huh um
we uh we are prepared we have all kinds
of evacuation kits in our garage we have
earthquake
evacuation kits we have fire evacuation
kits we have
covid and by the way any one of these
evacuation kits
will work in a pinch if i have an
argument with my wife and i get kicked
out of the house
grab one of them you can grab so you're
saying if if you have to suddenly leave
your wife because of a fight
you could grab an earthquake a covid or
a fire evacuation kit and just check
into a motel
yeah fire would be better because that
has a tent in it and i wouldn't
so if i see you if i'm driving around
the neighborhood and i see you in a tent
on the front yard
and yet there's been no fires i know
that you've had a fight with your wife
yeah and here's the thing also about the
the i wouldn't take the evacuation kit
because
i've been dipping into that like only
during like
tremors if there's a tremor i'll just
open up and take one little thing out
and eat it as an emotional
you know blanket a feeling of security
yeah
yeah so um the only thing left in the
evacuation in the
earthquake kit i think is just like a
can of tuna
white tuna and no can opener right i bet
no can opener ate that
last week you know i want to
i have a i have a complaint i have a
complaint to file with you which is you
have a very funny
uh show called hiking with kevin
where you get celebrity pals to hike
with you
i did it a while ago it must have been
what a year year and a half ago it was
about
two years ago now you're a year and a
half
anyway if you're gonna file a complaint
you're gonna have to get the accurate
date
all right well but let me just tell you
what the complaint is okay i did your
show and
just before i went out the door i just
grabbed a hat i don't even think it was
my hat it might have been my wife's hat
i don't know whose hat it was i
grabbed it and put it on my head and it
looked
terrible take a look let's show people
right
now there it is okay
you didn't stop me you didn't say
anything you didn't say hey conan that
hat looks
stupid you let me go out the door
and then you filmed me for your show and
it's been online and i'm taking a lot of
for that hat
why didn't you say something you're my
friend look
we're at a point in our friendship now
where you know you
i've always thought you did weird things
strange things i haven't always agreed
with your decisions or choices
so when i saw the hat i thought okay
he's making his bed he's going to sleep
in it
and it's a and a lot of people i mean i
have thousands of followers
have seen that you didn't realize how
popular my show was i didn't realize no
i didn't realize 100 people yeah
yeah i mean it wasn't a good look for me
it was not a good look but you went with
it
and you you believed it you know
they sold a lot of those hats after that
hike i don't know if you know they saw i
actually uh heard this from the
manufacturer of that hat
they saw a 100 increase in sales
because uh previously they had only sold
one
and then they sold another one yeah but
i think you know what
you you kind of generated a style with
that hat it was kind of like a
tom sawyer kind of a look yeah i looked
sort of like a tom sawyer if he had
leukemia
um not that good
nice nice nice slam good slam
now conan you you during the pandemic
i've noticed when you came over to my
house
you seem to be getting more fit and
bulkier are you
weight training i do weights i do
weights i wouldn't say i'm getting
bulkier
uh i'm thicker heavier heavier
no that's not no i'm not getting hit no
no
no i think i've taken good care of
myself during covid really good care
which makes me think that maybe you work
too hard
non-pandemic uh
times you know what i mean how much how
many painkillers are you on
right now
okay that's too much because sometimes
the sentence doesn't quite make it
doesn't come out right i don't know if
that's the
you know i have to choose my words very
carefully when i'm with you
because you're so judgmental i am not
judgmental
i'm a good friend are you telling me
that nobody would nobody else besides me
says you're judgmental
i am not judgmental very few people my
wife thinks i'm judgmental my assistant
thinks i'm judgmental and my family
thinks i'm the best
people that know me best think i'm
judgmental but your average person
doesn't think i'm judgmental and in fact
i find you guilty of calling me
judgmental
okay my point is proven and taken
okay how many painkills are you on right
now
i'm not i don't take pain pills we
established that earlier
i uh what can you name one painkiller
uh i don't think i can i don't really
know much about them
tequila oh tequila that's a painkiller
yeah i like tequila i like tequila in
the morning and i like to keel in the
afternoon you make tequila omelets in
the morning
yes i do yeah i like to pour a little
tequila in there it's a delicious
omelette
it's the best you know this is time
we'll never get back you know that don't
you
oh i'll get it back no no this is time
this is time uh americans have invested
in us
together they thought this was a good
bet they thought kevin ew and conan
o'brien that's a dynamic duo
and then they see a paint adult guy
standing
in a room with a banjo in the background
babbling about
um how i'm judgmental
which is just not true first of all i
expected you to be very defensive in
this conversation i am not defensive
and you have not proven me wrong i think
one day you'll take down that wall
and you will open up
and you will share your real feelings
with me and you'll take that mask
down yeah
we're going to get to that you mentioned
a really good thing which is that's the
name of your show and i know what you're
doing that you're promoting it was very
clever
it's a virtual comedy show right
yeah it's called kevin nealon behind the
mask
tell us about it you're right on target
it'll be on saturday september 12th at 7
p.m pacific standard time
i'm going to be doing stand-up comedy
i'm going to have an opener his name
is brad paisley wow you got brad paisley
to open for you
i can get anybody i want i could have
got you
sure i'm available i know i've done it
i know that probably don't want someone
coming out before you
who's super funny you know what i mean
here's the thing i don't want somebody
coming out before me that's so available
people could see you every night look at
me look at me i'm looking at you
i'll get hurt i'm just trying to explain
to you why you're not wanted
wait a minute yeah now i just want to
disclose that you and brad paisley are
friends you and i are friends but i
think you're even tighter with brad
paisley you guys are close
well brad can be real with me you know
he takes down that wall
uh-huh you don't know if you want to be
in a motorcycle gang
or if you want to become a lawyer
i don't know what you want to be i'm a
different i'm a shape-shifter i'm a
different person every single day yeah
so that's great so and then there's uh
i've known yeah the first time i met
um brad was about 20 years ago i didn't
say anything to him actually the first
time i had
i was too intimidated by him we're on
the same flight and
i was just so intimidated plus i didn't
want to have to walk all the way back to
coach to say hi to him
he's very frugal brad paisley and i
don't think i'm told
musicians of that caliber there's no
money in it that's what i'm told
they do it for the love yeah all for the
love but he's going to be opening up for
me he'll be doing about i don't know
12 to 15 minutes maybe some guitar
riffing some chatting
and then i'll come out through this door
probably
wow make my answers through that door
pretty exciting
yes where i'm having some carpenters
come over and make sure that door works
later today
uh-huh a lot of preparation going into
the show and then um
afterwards conan there's going to be a
virtual after party
where the viewers could interact with
brad and myself
and ask questions and chat and we'll
have libations there there's a two drink
minimum by the way that's
the system people have to go into their
own refrigerator and get out two drinks
that's great and then they have to make
sure you tip yourself
yeah you you know you're going a little
in and out of focus
either that or it's the painkillers
yeah i was gonna say i think how about
now is it good now
yeah now it's back i think you know what
happened conan and i have a camera on
top of my laptop
uh-huh it takes a while for it to find
the distance if i back up which i did
yeah because it's it's it's in
competition with the wall behind me
yeah this is all stuff above your head
no it's not above my head i could see it
i'll somebody explain it to you i could
see how for a moment the camera thought
the wall behind you was more compelling
than you it did
a zing zinger thing
that was not a thing at all was it a
zang no
that was a splat
you you'll know a zing when you hear it
from me okay
all right i thought i got you pretty
good there you know what time is the
band showing up behind you
what see your guitar back there yeah i
got a guitar i got one guitar back there
just i just need one guitar
create a sense of depth i know you've
got a lot of guitars back there we all
know you've got a lot of guitars are all
the guitars that i
shot and mounted on my wall they're all
stuffed
uh as long yeah uh you know what you're
uh you're a hunter of guitars
in the wild you know kevin i joke around
with you a lot and sometimes maybe i do
zing you give you a little twist of the
knife but it's out of love it's out of
real affection
probably probably i worry about you
though
i do worry about you why because i
think you feel like you're never enough
and for me you're not
not seriously that is a concern of mine
and yes i do feel
and and thank you for being honest i'm
not enough for you as right as a friend
as a
as a and by the way that's what i call a
zing
yeah yeah okay all right so you win
i guess again again
well i'm glad you're feeling better
kevin i didn't say that
okay i'm glad your shoulder you have a
new shoulder now shoulder is getting
better
yeah i feel like crap but the shoulder's
getting better well
um you know i think it's i think better
days are coming to be honest with you
i do too i'm optimistic i think i think
it's been a rough year for all of us i
think things are good
let me finish not for you
man well you're not a good guy but
you're not a bad guy either
uh kevin i've told you this before
when i'm with you it's like leaving
ireland you're exhausted because it's a
duel of the wits
always trying to outdo the other person
you get on the plane at the tarmac and
iron and you're like why am i so
exhausted
yeah it's because it's a constant
duel of one-upping yes
yes it happens everywhere i i did a
comedy show once in dublin and then
afterwards we
a bunch of me and a bunch of the other
comedians some of the funniest people
i've ever met
we got in a cab to go to uh a place to
get a drink
after the show and pub and we we get in
the
the cab the cabbie was funnier than all
of us
that's ireland it's crazy yeah yeah
ridiculous
i understand that um i don't know how we
got on this i think you took us
off in this i was trying to make it a
little more interesting
yeah you did a great that's good
again i'm drawn to the wall behind you
do you feel like kind of
uh armageddon and you're like a lone
survivor and you've chosen the largo
theater to
yeah this is my last stand the largo
theater on la cienega
in uh in la this is my last stand it's
gonna be here
it's warm i like the lighting and it
looks comfortable
yeah yeah well i'm sitting down i'm well
lit
and then there's your situation okay
kevin behind the mask streams live on
saturday
tickets are available on rushtix.com
tix yes
tix well you ended with a bang
and let me just add one thing conan to
finish
the job for you brad paisley will be
opening once again
there'll be an after party yep tickets
are available on rush
what rush ticks tix.com
i like it i like it you're you are
easily easy to train yeah if you were a
dog i would teach you so many tricks
well get oh look at that the time is up
oh where did the time go
i can tell you it's all here and uh
there's a lot of it
i hope you can use some of this kevin
yes we're going to use
at least six percent kevin i'm a fan i
continue to be a fan
you're a friend i'm glad you're on the
mend and i look forward to seeing your
show
and i want you to be happy i just want
you to be happy and
know that you are enough right i hey i
know how to make myself happy right now
that's all the time we have for kevin
nealon
thank you kevin okay thank you conor